[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com i'm going to need us as a
collective community of critical
thinkers to think very carefully about
what I am about to report to you and it
relates to an interview that Donald
Trump gave to Reuters yesterday and in
this interview Donald Trump said that
he's worried that what he says to robert
muller if he agrees to be interviewed by
robert muller or his investigators as
part of this trump russia investigation
Trump believes that what he says to
Muller would be used to bring perjury
charges against him in that
investigation now let's look at the
wording that Donald Trump used in the
interview when he said this because this
is sort of the foundation upon which our
analysis will be built Trump said quote
yesterday so if I say something and he
Comey says something else and it's my
word against his and he's best friends
with Muller so Muller might say well I
believe Comey and even if I'm telling
the truth that makes me a liar that's no
good so the easy reading of this is hey
if you don't want to be charged with
perjury don't lie to investigators
federal agents period the argument that
Trump and his lawyers are making and
have been making is that Donald Trump's
statements will be unfairly used to
charge him with perjury Meany merely at
the discovery of any discrepancy with
what another witness has said Trump will
be unfairly charged with perjury so
there's two really important elements to
analyze here once is this concept of a
perjury trap and then the other is that
Trump is effectively pleading the fifth
here I want to talk more about perjury
trap because this is the the
misinformation around that has gotten so
ridiculous that we've got to pick it
apart but let's start with the pleading
the fifth thing here Donald Trump is not
literally pleading the fifth which lets
you not
if I against yourself in order to avoid
self-incrimination but what Trump is
doing is effectively it's like a de
facto pleading the fifth Trump is
worried that his statements will be self
incriminating fairly or unfairly Trump
would say unfairly so Trump is
considering not giving statements to
Robert Muller
now Trump has said time and again that
innocent people don't plead the fifth
remember this as just one example shoes
people take you in the Fifth Amendment
for people plus the guy who illegally
did the server you know he put in the
illegal server so there are five people
taking the Fifth Amendment like you see
on the mob right you see the mob takes
of it if you're innocent why you taking
the Fifth Amendment yeah so there are
many of these I won't play them all I
won't show you all the tweets it's been
applied to Hillary Clinton to staffers
to people in Trump's business past all
sorts of people that Trump is said if
you're innocent you don't plead the
fifth
so Trump once again if you aren't guilty
when law enforcement wants to talk to
you you talk to them and Trump is
violating his own standard here but the
reason why he would say he's violating
it is because here there is this unfair
desire to set a perjury trap against
Trump let's break this down first of all
what is perjury perjury is when you
willfully tell an untruth in a court or
investigation under oath this can
include to a grand jury this can include
to investigators perjury is the willful
telling of untruths you're not going to
be charged with perjury if your comments
because of lack of recollection or lack
of specificity or lack of detail simply
don't align with what another witness
said because perjury is the willful
telling of lies and perjury convictions
are difficult to get because it's tough
to figure out legally speaking or to
prove legally speaking that someone was
willfully telling lies so Trump's
framing that any accidental or
coincidental inaccuracies or conflicts
with what for example James Comey has
told Robert Muller will get him charged
with perjury are ridiculous at their
face because perjury conviction
are really difficult to get and
prosecutors aren't going to just
willy-nilly try to get soft perjury
charges in this way but the most
important part of this is not the
definition of perjury which again means
the willful telling of untruths a
perjury trap is a real thing but it's
prosecutorial misconduct prosecutors get
in trouble for setting perjury traps
even though it happens incredibly rarely
and there is a definition for what it
means to set a perjury trap a perjury
trap is when you call a witness in to
testify without any real suspicion that
the person has already committed crimes
solely with the intent of getting them
to lie under oath to make that the one
and only crime that you charge them with
perjury traps almost never happen at the
federal level and in fact no US federal
court has ever accepted a motion to
dismiss because of claimed perjury traps
period okay we already know that molars
team has been talking to everybody from
Trump's personal lawyer Michael Cohen to
White House lawyer dun began to
everybody in between about actions taken
by Trump that might constitute
obstruction of justice by definition
that already means the perjury trap
accusation would be bogus if trump
perjures himself it is not a trap set
without any reason to think Trump may
have already committed other crimes
Trump is part of this because he may
have committed other crimes perjury
traps are when you have nothing on
somebody and you want to get them to
perjure themselves it simply doesn't
apply here yeah it is bogus but it's
what the Trump lawyers have to go with
this has to be their strategy because
Trump is a pathological liar I mean he
just speaks that way he speaks in
hyperbole so there's no way he could go
into an interview with robert muller and
not come out of it having told 10-plus
live and it's not even the hyperbole
it's that he thinks he's smarter than
everybody else and they won't be able to
figure out whether he's lying and
unfortunately even though I'm telling
you don't fall for the perjury trap
nonsense and there are some other
journalists telling you don't fall for
the perjury trap nonsense Rudy Giuliani
is doing a really good job of spreading
the nonsense and people are starting to
buy it they are starting to believe that
a perjury trap is being set for Donald
Trump here when it literally does not
apply to the circumstances by the way
also notable Trump said in the same
interview with Reuters that if he wanted
to he could take over the Moller
investigation but he's choosing not to
Trump said quote I can go in and I could
do whatever I could run it if I want but
I decided to stay out I'm totally
allowed to be involved if I wanted to be
so far I haven't chosen to be involved
I'll stay out legally I mean who knows
if that's the case I don't I'm worn out
from the perjury trap debunking that I
don't even have the energy to get into
that part he wants the Russian officials
to also investigate their own meddlings
yeah we can have Trump and the Russians
investigate Trump Russia that'd be great
Putin made an incredible offer which is
that Trump can partner with Russians and
they together can investigate
I guess themselves because they are the
ones at this point suspected of the
wrongdoing okay yesterday I told you
about this book which claims that Donald
Trump is a Mafia owned Russian asset the
book is called house of Trump house of
Putin the untold story of Donald Trump
and the Russian mafia it's by
investigative journalist Craig Unger and
one claim made in the book among many is
that
Unger said to Newsweek during an
interview about the book that he has a
reason to believe there's a Russian
asset in the White House who Unger
believes is an actual Russian agent but
that part is not 100% clear but at
minimum that there is a Russian asset
working at the White House that is tied
to Russian intelligence I don't know if
the story I'm about to tell you is
related to Craig angers book or not it's
not clear whether this is the person
that Unger was thinking about or talking
about but Democrats in the House of
Representatives are now investigating
national security adviser John Bolton's
ties to the same suspected Russian spy
Marie abou Tina who was recently
indicted and this is just a stunning
convergence of multiple angles of the
Fiasco that is the Trump administration
and I'm gonna do my best to break it
down for you because it's starting to
get very convoluted we've got Part A
which is Craig angers claimed that
there's a Russian asset working at the
White House
Part B from a few weeks ago is that
Maria boo Tina was indicted for being an
unregistered foreign agent
and for conspiracy to act she is
believed to be an agent of the Russian
government working in the United States
on Russia's behalf without properly
disclosing it
we learned that booty nough got access
not only to high-level executives at the
National Rifle Association which has
been a possible and likely conduit of
Russian money to the Trump campaign boo
Tina also got access to officials at the
Federal Reserve boo Tina got access to
officials at the Treasury Department and
to at least one congressman that we know
about our friend congressman Russia as I
know him Dana Rohrabacher a Republican
from California what we now have our
Democratic congressman Elijah Cummings
and Stephen Lynch who want documents
from chief of staff John Kelly related
to whether John Bolton reported his
previous work with this alleged Russian
spy on his security clearance forms or
on other White House vetting materials
it's suspected that the current national
security adviser to the President of the
United States john bolton
trump's third NSA by the way is tied
directly to suspected Russian spy maria
boo tina through a video that bolton
participated in for a booty 'no
organized gun rights roundtable
promoting gun rights in russia
this actually was reported months ago by
NPR this was in March of 2018 at the
time bolton wasn't yet the national
security adviser he became national
security advisor in april and the
details reported by NPR did not get as
much attention as they probably should
have and what we now know is that in
2013 john bolton participated in a
roundtable discussion organized by the
same maria boo tina who has been
indicted and what democrats are asking
for our documents related to whether
bolton discussed the contacts that he no
doubt had with someone presumably boo
tina if not others involved in that
group when he was invited and agreed to
participate in this russian gun rights
thing which by the way how who even gets
involved in
advocating for Russian gun rights I
guess the NRA wants it because it helps
them sell more guns for their clients I
don't know but every time you shake a
tree as I saw written on Reddit
yesterday a Russian drops out of it and
I what is the explanation going to be my
guess is if you ask me do I think that
Bolton put anything about the work he
did with this Russian gun rights group
and his contacts potentially with boo
Tina herself on his sf-86 forum my guess
is like Jared Kushner he forgot to
include that on the forum yeah I mean in
response they'll just deny everything
here and I think they can get away with
that especially because even I'm
skeptical about this connection in a way
because john bolton is a neocon and you
know his words and actions haven't
exactly been pro-russia throughout the
years sure like he supports regime
change in Syria which of course Putin in
Bashar al-assad are aligned he also said
that the 2016 election meddling was an
act of war and that the u.s. negotiates
with Russia at its peril so I'm gonna
hold out judgement for now well then if
there's no reason to hide these contacts
I'm sure that they are on his sf-86 form
right yeah I'd love to see that si form
yup
I think they're probably not on there
and this is listen this is just Trump's
national security adviser he mostly gets
coffee and makes dinner reservations for
people on Trump staff this is not like a
oh wait a second it's the National
Security Advisor
yeah that's pretty serious so let's get
those records but I don't think anybody
will be surprised if the sf-86 forum is
missing any reference to this
organization or to Maria boo Tina or
whoever his contact was and what I want
to remind you of it's now gonna have to
become a daily reminder Pat's furious
with me that I'm doing this but it has
to be a daily reminder
nothing will happen unless Republicans
lose control on November 6 2018
period let's make it happen let me know
on Twitter
what you think about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show the david pakman
show at david pakman
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the David Pakman show is
independent progressive media and it's
mostly funded by great people in our
audience through the membership program
today two of those great people out our
new member of the day Robert raining and
sustaining member of the day Rick cook
who's been with us since 2013
Robert Rick thank you join them vote
with your dollars for media you support
at WWJ in pokémon comm coupon code is
available if you want the discount
there's no vetting okay it's not
means-tested if you want the discount
you can get 40% off with the coupon code
vote soon 18 if you don't want the
discount then by all means pay full
price and we appreciate everybody
regardless of how much they pay maybe we
can't keep giving out these discounts I
was looking at the numbers yeah it's
unsustainable Pat's concerned he made a
frantic 3 a.m. phone call not to Michael
Flynn but to our attorney I'm sorry to
our accountant and notified him about
all these discounts that are flying out
the door now take the discount by all
means I welcome people who take the
discount I have been very critical of
Alexandria Acacio Cortese when she
doesn't know stuff or when she says
things that don't make sense and have
actually been so critical of her that
people in the audience have written to
me and they said David you're not being
fair to her even if she's not an expert
on every issue she has the right ideas
and we should support her because she
will learn by doing so my point in
pressing the story with that is to
remind you that I am by no means an
irrational knee-jerk defender of
Alexandria Casio Cortes if anything I'm
the opposite I've been critical where I
feel she deserves criticism she is now
being slammed completely unfairly as
some articles have put it for quote
banning the press from her events the
truth is that what Alexandria Acacio
courts has did is hold some town halls
in New York that were open to the public
but media was not allowed in this is
part of a listening tour that she did in
the Bronx
Queens that's where she's running and
she's being slammed for banning the
press she's being completely pillaged
for lack of transparency and these
criticisms I hate to break it to you are
completely ridiculous and absolutely
fabricated her response on Twitter to
this controversy was to say that quote
our community is 50% immigrant folks are
victims of domestic violence trafficking
and have personal medical issues this
town hall was designed for residents to
feel safe discussing sensitive issues in
a threatening political time we
indicated previously that it would be
closed to press this is a stupid reason
to criticize her if you want to go after
Alexandria Acacio cortes because she
said silly things about the unemployment
rate go ahead and do it if you want to
critique her because she seems confused
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
if that's what you believe then go ahead
and critique her for that if you want to
even debate the merits of a listening
tour have that debate okay I have no
problem with that even if you want to
debate whether closing events to press
is a good or bad idea as a campaign
strategy have that conversation but
having events that are close to the
press is just not a story and you
devalue your criticisms when you say
that this is tantamount to banning the
press or in any way censorship and it is
these angry irate people who are crying
wolf
every single member of Congress I think
everyone if not almost everyone has
private fundraising events there is no
press scrutiny other than general
scrutiny of we would like to know what
it is that they are saying to donors
behind closed doors and of course I also
would like to know this is a town hall
for constituents and the press is simply
not guaranteed access to everything
Alexandria Acacio cortes does criticize
ur where it matters where it makes sense
but this is simply dumb and you know if
you're outraged that a candidate met
with a donor in private okay well let's
let's talk about that if you're outraged
that an elected official Grit gave a
private speech somewhere let's talk
about that but this was not a Prescott
France and this is not even a defense of
her policies or her ideas this is merely
saying this is a completely manufactured
scandal you don't have to allow press
into everything you do and it's
perfectly reasonable to meet with would
be or actual constituents without media
in there and it is a devaluing of the
criticisms of Alexandria Acacio Cortez
to go after her for this yeah I mean if
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez never allowed
the media into her speaking engagements
then maybe we'd have something
approaching a scandal or if she allowed
MSNBC and Mother Jones into the room but
you know not Fox News and Breitbart
okay we could have that conversation
we're not approaching any of this stuff
there's just nothing here there's
nothing here and it is a total joke to
see people on the right but also even
some on the left fall for criticizing
her about this and it there are plenty
of things about which Alexandria Acacio
Cortes should be criticized and I've
criticized her for some of those but the
fact that sometimes she meets with
constituents or would-be constituents
without the media there is simply not a
story I have a completely surreal piece
of video to play for you our fearless
orange leader Donald Trump did an event
at the White House yesterday to honor
some officials that are in Border Patrol
immigration customs officials who did
great things and at a certain point
during this event Donald Trump brings an
officer on stage who is apparently
Hispanic and mentions in his invite for
the officer to come on stage that the
officer quote speaks perfect English why
is this even a topic of discussion well
we'll talk about that here's the video
and audio from Donald Trump Adrienne
come here I want to ask you a question
so how did you come to commit you're not
nervous
speaks perfect English come here I want
to ask you about that 78 lives you saved
78 people so how did you feel that there
were people in that trailer
so remember Trump is the least racist
person period yes as he has stated many
times we later found out that the
officer in question is Adrienne Anzaldua
and Trump was just stunned apparently
not only that Adrienne spoke perfect
English but that he wasn't drinking a
corona and wearing a sombrero and
playing in a mariachi band during his
off time this is I I'm sort of like
perplexed here as to how this is even
considered a reasonable thing to say
obviously Trump wouldn't note that a
white guy speaks perfect English but he
notes that a Hispanic guy speaks perfect
English and I guess the one reason
perfect English should be notable to
Trump is that Trump speaks far from
perfect English but again that should be
know about everybody not just the
Hispanic guy so this is old-fashioned
stereotyping and Prejudice period I
don't even know that we need like a
serious deep analysis of the thing it's
like calling a black guy so articulate
in a context where there's no particular
reason where we would question how
articulate a black guy or anybody is and
when you're talking to a Hispanic
American I guess if they look Hispanic
it becomes notable if they speak good
English to Donald Trump yes that simple
I feel like we don't even have to
provide commentary on this story like we
could have just played that 17 second
video and the end of the story Mexico is
sending rapists it's sending criminals
and some I assume are good people and I
guess here happens to be one of them
even though we don't actually know
whether whether Adrienne as all to us is
from Mexico I actually don't even know
whether he's a naturalized citizen he
may have been born in the United States
for all I know could be either way
plenty of Border Patrol agents who are
both naturalized American citizens and
Hispanic Americans who were born in the
United States could be either you
shouldn't hear his words he has the best
words the best language best vocabulary
great guy I had a situation yesterday I
have the opposite problem that Adrienne
has with Donald Trump which is I because
I am very very white as some of you may
have noticed but I am a Hispanic
American in a sense
I'm a Hispanic immigrant from Argentina
who learned English as a Second Language
I had an appointment at a bank to have
something notarized yesterday and the
notary was Hispanic and I believe from
Puerto Rico and she was taken aback she
was speaking Spanish to another customer
when I arrived so I just spoke to her in
Spanish and she said that is really good
how did you learn that and I said no the
questions how did I learn English I'm
from Argentina and she was stunned and I
kind of loved those my girlfriend was
saying to me you seemed to really relish
when that happens and I said I do I
really do like it everyone's using
stereotypes to some degree and shouldn't
necessarily know that you speak Spanish
she would probably assume that you
learned it as a second language and it's
a fair assumption I guess I don't know
about that I mean you would think that
she would be able to tell that I'm not
an English as a second I'm sorry Spanish
as a second language speaker if you're a
native Spanish speakers the accent yeah
I don't know anyway it was I had a great
time and it was a beautiful beautiful
afternoon that I had yesterday so as far
as the trunk video I don't think I
really have to say too much else here's
where I think we can most productively
take the story if you're sick of
headlines like these Trump ridicules
disabled reporter Trump finds it notable
that a Hispanic American speaks perfect
English Trump ruins and other
geopolitical alliance if you're sick of
it register to vote in November go to
vote gov if you think you're registered
confirm that by going to head count org
if you want to help Democrats defeat
Republicans in November go to my
Democrats org nearly 40% of Americans
support this stuff many of them even
like this stuff and we've got to vote
them all out if you are not following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show you literally don't
know what you're missing because you're
not following us on instagram please do
go to instagram.com slash david pakman
show or search for david pakman show on
instagram you can also follow me I am
David Pakman on instant quick break back
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to be
joined today by Ken Jennings who holds
the record for consecutive Jeopardy wins
at 74 games he's earned over 4 million
dollars on game shows and is now an
author whose latest book is called
planet funny how comedy took over our
culture ken I've so many things to ask
you about different things and and it's
just really great to talk to you so
thank you for taking the time that's a
pleasure thanks for having me
so let's start with a little bit of
Jeopardy stuff so just to let's get see
if we can clarify some of the very
common misperceptions that people might
have about how the game works you are
not liable to be asked about literally
anything on a particular episode the
guests the contestants have a sense of
the topics that will be part of a
particular show is that correct that is
a very common misconception for some
reason I have no idea why people think
that but I think
vast swathes of America assume that the
contestants know what the categories are
going to be on Jeopardy on a given night
and that's not true the contestants
don't see those categories until the
same time the home viewers do and Alec
says let's see what the categories are
nuclear physics gangster rap and that's
the first time we've seen them now have
you gotten any study material even
without having a delineation of the
categories or do you get nothing it's
just show up and whatever's in your head
is what what you're going to have to go
on absolutely nothing I mean if you've
been watching the show for 35 years like
many people have you have some sense of
the kinds of things
jeopardy will ask the style of the
questions you know there's gonna be
presidents and world capitals there's
kind of a Canon but no you have no idea
going in on that day whether it's going
to be hockey or country music or the
franco-prussian war okay
how much of success on the game show
depends on one the the facts you have in
your head versus to the right timing for
when you buzz in I mean you can't win
without both you know somebody without
the facts has zero chance to win but the
thing is the show has a very tough
audition process like everybody there
had to pass a very difficult simulation
of a Jeopardy game so on any given night
all three of the players and most of the
players know most of the answers most of
the time and because of that it really
does come down to in practice it turns
out to be like 8020 buzzer because
everybody knows all the answers and it's
just who can get in first and is there a
downside to so I guess what what is the
secret to the buzzer timing because you
can't you can't buzz in too early either
right right often on the show you'll see
somebody just ern wailing away on their
buzzer and you think oh that poor guy
has things not working the fix is in
do they not like Canadians what's going
on and in fact what happens is you can't
just buzz whenever you know it you have
to wait for Alex to finish reading the
question or the clue and then at that
point some assistant somewhere flips a
switch and activates all the buzzer and
then your buzzers live if you buzz in
before that point you actually get
locked out for a fraction of a second so
when you see somebody doing this what
you're seeing is somebody who got so
adrenaline dump they buzz too early you
have to be in this very zen state where
you hear Alex's voice died away you wait
like a brief syllable length pause and
then you just jam your thumb on that
thing is if your life depended on it
okay so as the wings start racking up
and I remember I don't note and remember
exactly how old I was when this was
going on but I do remember it as the
winds start racking up what is the first
sign or are there signs that the
producers are starting to say you know
that this we never really accounted for
a streak that was this long this maybe
isn't how the game is is designed to go
and then part two of the question is is
there a point at which the streak takes
on a life of its own and then it becomes
a really great thing for the show that's
exactly what happened this was a very
recent rule change about a year after I
auditioned when they called me to say
hey we have a slot in three weeks they
said
hey we've got this new rule change
contestants are no longer gonna get
retired forcibly after five games it
used to be kind of a Logan's Run thing
where you won five games they gave you a
car and the next night they had all new
people right and I was and I was like oh
well thanks for letting me know but that
is very unlikely to affect me and sure
enough that's what happened it the
change just happened a month a few
months ago I'm sure they kind of wanted
the excitement of a long streak but
maybe they were thinking 7 or 9 games
it was a long streak I don't think they
were planning on six months and the
contestants don't get that you don't get
to chat with the producers there's very
strict security you know because of the
laws on the on the federal books about
rigging game shows you don't get any
time face time with anybody who might
know the answer it's not Alex not the
producers nobody who actually runs the
show so there were a few conference
calls where they wanted me to do
publicity where I could tell they were a
little nervous you know and and I've
since heard were interactively yes
behind the scenes they were terrified
what if I had just broken jeopardy after
30 years and at one point on one of
these calls I asked at what point do you
just like you know forcibly retire me at
what point do I just Alexei all right
ken we've decided you've been on long
enough and there's a long pause and they
say our rule say a contestant plays
he'll he or she loses right and and they
had so they had 48 I think shows of me
in the can before any of them started to
air so they've got months of me and they
have no way of knowing if people are
gonna hate it or like it right and when
they finally started the area did kind
of organically turn into a thing Jeffrey
didn't promote it but people just
started saying hey this guy's been on
for like two weeks you got to watch this
and then SportsCenter started covering
it and it turned into a thing and it
turned out to be very good for their
ratings but they didn't know that going
in now if they were determined to get
you off the show there are probably ways
that they could do it that wouldn't
violate sort of the structure or the
rules right like maybe I don't know
really figuring out what you're unlikely
to know much about and stacking those
categories or I guess I'm just imagining
being a producer like if they said we've
got to get this guy off there's probably
ways they could do it without breaking
the rules or the law though they have as
long as they follow the guidelines that
they've given to all contestants so that
they you know generally follow the
pretty much do what they want that's
what they're independent there's like an
agency that little monitor stuff for
them and that's where they'll get told
just follow your guidelines and don't do
anything specific anyone contested but
in their case their practice was to
select all the material blindly and
randomly so it actually would have
violated their own practices interesting
to give like anti-can questions whatever
those are and but there were a few
things they could do and they were smart
changes they need to level the playing
field they came back from hiatus and
they had changed their daily schedule of
contestant warm-ups so that the the new
contestants the challengers got much
more time to practice on the stage with
the buzzer the practices were rehearsing
were much more similar to the actual
show interesting and that's what the
games did get a lot closer and I felt
very proud of that it was like they had
you know it's like widening the the lane
in the NBA for Wilt Chamberlain or
whatever you know right had to change
the rules for me that is fascinating
so now I guess we can start getting into
what you're doing now and I think a good
lead-in to that will be correct me if
I'm wrong but the perception I had of
how you started to be sort of
caricatured in media that reported on
the streak was as the sort of very
wholesome character and I don't know if
that was on the basis like of of
religion or your physical appearance or
your demeanor or what do you agree that
that's kind of like the character that
was built up about you independently of
like whether it's accurate or not was
that sort of the Ken Jennings of the
media yeah I think so I'm kind of an
opiate looking guy I was a Mormon guy
who I'm a Mormon guy who was living in
Salt Lake City Utah at the time and the
one thing everybody on Jeopardy
generally seems kind of bland and
milquetoast you can't really there's no
way to create a character of someone
based on their jeopardy appearances
because most people are the format does
not lend itself to any kind of
showboating or character work so yeah
insofar as people were writing about me
they were saying you know this wholesome
guy from Utah but I actually was like a
suburban dad from from deeply Mormon
Utah that was not too far off so then I
saw that when you now have you have a
twitter account now I don't know when it
when it started but you have a Twitter
account and you also write
and on the Twitter account you sometimes
do make political statements or or make
comments about politics and it seems
like in when I look at the comments
people are like extra put off in a sense
if it seems like their politics don't
align with yours and I don't know why
like is the idea that because you you
were on Jeopardy and they saw you as
this very sort of narrow
question-answering guy that it's not
okay all of a sudden for you to have
political opinions or like are you
surprised by some of the feedback you
get when you make political posts on
Twitter I mean well that's just part of
Twitter is you'll have athletes or
comedians or whatever who are like we
shouldn't be separating kids from their
parents and you know every conservative
will be like stick to comedy or stick to
baseball or whatever you know that's
that's just the phenomenon of public
life we you know you should have no
opinions once you decide to play
baseball or whatever and it's probably
intensified in my case just because
Jeopardy's audience friends old yeah so
you have a lot of baby boomers you have
a lot of kind of graying America
including a lot of red state Americans
watching the show and I'm sure some of
them are like he seemed so nice when he
was on Jeopardy with Alex but now look
what he's saying about our president you
know so I think there is some of that so
let's talk a little bit about comedy
because your book planet funny how
comedy took over our culture makes a lot
of very interesting analyses of what's
going on within the comedy world and I
feel like lately especially comedy has
become such a way to satirize politics
and and sometimes it's almost become
comedy writers have had a pretty tough
job lately because even their wildest
and wackiest ideas don't actually seem
that much further than what we're
experiencing in the real world what's
your sense of the way in which comedy
and satire has worked its way even into
sort of the most serious elements of
society is that a good thing or is that
something that can make serious issues
seem not serious that fire is very old
you know the plays of Aristophanes
thousands of years ago are full of sat
there it's certainly not a new idea to
make jokes about the government and
we're not even in the first age where
people were like well satire is dead
things are too crazy
you can find quotes of people Tom Lehrer
said that about Watergate in Vietnam you
know that you can't be a satirist in the
area of water day in Vietnam this
stuff's do crazy and I remember Conan
O'Brien saying that at the height of the
the Bill Clinton kind of star up there
you know like there's sex jokes on page
one how do we do how do we do comedy now
and what is unprecedented now is I think
kind of the blurring of the line between
politics between actual policy and
current events and what the comedians
are saying you have a generation of kids
getting their news from comedy shows and
that has some unintended consequences
actually there's some research showing
that you know Jon Stewart fans who got
their news from The Daily Show you know
I think he was trying to he was a
passionate man trying to inspire people
to take a point of view and point out
problems in the world using humor and
instead what happened is he made a
generation of kids pretty cynical people
who watched that show were very
convinced that the media and politics
were broken and their response from it
was to disengage it did not help voting
rates it did not helpful itical activism
yeah I mean I guess the one thing it did
do is they were they were quite informed
in other words there were a number of
interesting polls which showed that they
did seem to be closely aligned with the
facts to a greater degree than somebody
who was primarily consuming actual
serious news you're bringing up sort of
the second layer effect which is well
what did they do with that information
and sadly the voting rates of that
demographic are not impressively high as
you're pointing out yeah it just seems
like today when there's such an
abundance of satire we can see that it's
kind of impotent you know we see a
hilarious joke about Trump online or you
know some epic John Oliver takedown and
we're like yeah I'm gonna retweet this
I've done my part and it turns out that
actually does nothing you know activism
might work voting might work but really
satire often is a way for people to kind
of blow off steam and feel like they've
helped which actually benefits those in
power it's it becomes a yeah a steam
vent that avoids actual pressure
building up I'm curious what you think
about Mena I'm trying to figure out the
right way to set this up but there's
certainly ones like right now we're in
the middle of this n-word controversy
with Omarosa and so on and so forth
the use of the n-word is an example for
us
is seen very differently if it is
satirical versus not satirical and there
are very divergent views about that and
even in satire can anybody use the word
or can only some people use the word
what's your sense more generally about
the idea that discriminatory offensive
or prejudicial things that would not be
acceptable outside of satire become
acceptable merely by calling them comedy
like is that a good thing is it
problematic in some ways I think we used
to give comedians a pretty wide carve
out you know they were kind of a special
protected class we needed our court
jesters and so it pretty much was a get
out of jail card to be like oh that was
just a joke right so you'd have you have
comedians make if he jokes about race or
class or war or whatever taboo topics
and they could say oh that's just a joke
and I'm kind of glad we've reached the
end of that because it's kind of a
cop-out right I mean of course it's a
joke but it's an utterance it's out
there in the air like any other it
affects listeners like any other and I
think it's fair to ask follow-up
questions like okay Roseanne you said
you were joking boo
what does that mean to compare an
african-american woman to an ape like
what did you think the consequences of
that are what might the real-world
implications of that be because this is
another area where there is good
research if you give a set of subjects
discriminatory jokes diss parents mid
humor they call it and then you compare
it to people who received
non-disparagement humor you know might
banal jokes and a third group that
received discriminatory material that
was not in humor form the first group
gets affected the most that's the thing
that will affect behavior something
about humor couching a difficult idea or
controversial idea it within a joke
allows it to seep into our brains and
maybe subconsciously affect the way we
act people who listen to that material
is more likely to react in a
discriminatory way when given follow up
tasks so I think it's not a joke at all
I'm I'm glad you know I don't want to
say it's the thought police now because
there is no such thing but I'm glad
we're examining jokes more to see what
their real-world impact might be the
book is fascinating it's called planet
funny how comedy took over our culture
we've been speaking with the book's
author Ken Jennings Ken really great
talking to you today the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
a very bizarre and disturbing story
ended tragically when a toddler was
stabbed to death by a Texas man who was
the toddler's own father who yelled
Jesus is coming as he was stabbing the
toddler the toddler was 16 months old
a witness explained that during the
attack once again Jesus his coming was
being yelled by the dad this happened in
the middle of the day in Lewisville
Texas no one has been identified as of
this morning the police captain says
this was probably the worst incident
he's seen in 20 years as a police
officer a neighbor who heard the
commotion came out with their gun fired
three shots that the dad fortunately
didn't hit the toddler one did hit the
dad in the leg a woman threw a garbage
can at the dad and ultimately the ending
completely tragic as the 16 month old
was brought to the hospital and died
there the dads been arrested he was
treated for the gunshot wound to the leg
the neighbor who fired the gun is not
going to be facing any criminal charges
now we don't yet know what charges will
be filed against the father but I think
it's safe to assume they're going to be
very very serious and right away what I
it's yet another horrible story of a
crime in the United States what I want
to talk about is the immediate
discussion that started after the the
incident of evil person versus mentally
ill person versus religious nut right
that is the debate that started around
the story and this is always a tough
thing to talk about and more than likely
almost everyone listening will disagree
with me on some level or maybe even find
themselves extraordinarily offended with
some of my commentary but let's go
through it piece by piece
first of all speaking very generally I
think that almost everyone who commits
this type of crime serial murder
gruesome individual murders terrorism
mass shootings on some level there is
mental illness these are not balanced
actions you can argue and say well it's
mostly evil with some mental illness but
the truth is that most people in most
situations are not going to end up
killing their kid and untreated mental
illness is
a factor although not necessarily the
only factor now there are other people
who will hear the story and they'll
focus in on the yelling of Jesus is
coming right they'll say listen the guy
was yelling about Jesus this is a
religiously inspired crime this is a
religious nut and religion made him do
it
but we got to think critically about
that as well I'm a top critic of
religion you all know that often I am
criticized for being too harsh about
religion but I think that's simply
saying religion made him do it is a
little bit too far let's sort of hear
both sides of that right one side would
be well Christianity includes in its
primary sacred texts a story of God
telling a man to kill his own son and
the man was about to do I think that's
the story of Abraham right yeah
until God told him hey you know what I
was just testing your faith you don't
actually have to kill your son they tell
that story as a beautiful story of God's
relationship to his followers and how
you can always trust God because
ultimately he'll have you do the right
thing or whatever but a dad was about to
kill his kid so there's no shortage of
like equally abhorrent behavior in the
Christian Bible but just because the guy
yelled Jesus is coming doesn't mean
Christianity made him do it any more
than you know the followers of Jim Jones
believed that they should kill their
children with cyanide because of the
doctrine of Jones Jones may have put him
over the edge but they were suggesting
they were often traumatized troubled
individuals and it could be Jim Jones or
it could be Christianity or Islam or
Alex Jones conspiracy theories that push
them over the edge but anything could
have pushed him over the edge
and of course most Christians don't kill
their kids regardless of how devout
their religious beliefs are this is not
an excuse for the disastrous impact of
extreme religious belief in the world
it's not that at all but what I am
telling you if that is that if this guy
had been Muslim he would have been
yelling something in Arabic maybe and
many people would be blaming Islam and
saying it's a terrorist attack even
though the religion in this case seems
to be an outlet to the insanity but not
actually the cause and then lastly is
the question of drugs
often a factor we just don't know in
this case certainly could be an
important causal element we know that a
significant portion of people who commit
certain crimes are under the influence
of drugs and alcohol at the time that
they do it doesn't mean that those
substances are solely responsible but
the point is it's not as easy as saying
this is merely a mentally ill person
this is merely a religious nut send me
your thoughts about how we should
consider religion in these stories where
it seems more incidental than causal
Google is accused in a lawsuit of
tracking the movements of iPhone and
Android users even when privacy settings
have turned location history off and
supposedly don't allow this type of
tracking there is this feature called
location history on your phone you
aren't supposed to be physically tracked
by Google when you turn that off and
your location history places you visited
aren't supposed to be stored there's a
new lawsuit against Google which says
it's not true Google is tracking you
either way class-action lawsuit has been
filed on behalf of people who turned off
or at least believed that they had
turned off Google's location tracking
feature the lawsuit which is filed in
California claims that this violates
California law computer science
researchers at Princeton University got
involved and they confirmed that yes
indeed tracking was happening even when
location history had been turned off the
Help section of Google's website now
says that turning location history off
quote does not affect other location
services and that some location data may
be saved through other services like
search and maps is this shocking the
answer is obviously no what can we do
about it the answer is I don't know if
the lawsuit gets Google to change the
policy then okay that might be one step
forward but the truth is the way that
that is written there are many other
ways for Google to follow that by the
letter
not in spirit let me give you an example
if you turn location services off and
you are no longer tracked via GPS even
if you turn off GPS services altogether
on your phone the Wi-Fi you connect to
is easy to geolocate for google and they
would know where you are based on the
Wi-Fi networks that you're connecting to
IP scanning where you restaurants and
places that you look up there are
countless other ways even with GPS
services turned off never mind location
history turned off that Google can track
you
so the question very quickly becomes Pat
are you switching to MapQuest because of
this I'm gonna have to I mean I thought
that when I turned off my location
history on Friday night when I go to all
the places I like to go to that it was
totally fine but apparently not and even
eggnog me no Moe's got not gonna help me
but seriously you're not actually sound
I'm not changing you're not and I'm not
either and some people will say well if
if you don't take a stand then this
isn't going to get any better I still
think it doesn't really matter because
you can be tracked by IP address not as
precisely you can be tracked in a bunch
of other ways and even if the
class-action lawsuit is hugely
successful millions and millions of
people were impacted by this and every
single one of them is entitled to $15 if
they fill out complex class action
lawsuit forms and wait 18 months it's
still not going to make a huge
difference and most people aren't even
going to do it because the paperwork for
these things is extraordinarily onerous
so I I am concerned about this I am NOT
someone who says if I'm not concerned
about them knowing what I'm doing
I shouldn't be concerned about them
having more access than I want them to
have I don't fall for that I think that
is a slip I I resist slippery slopes
many times I think that actually is
opening the door to a slippery slope or
I just don't think we can do anything
about or if you're not doing anything
wrong then you have nothing to worry
about about that one thing I am NOT
someone who subscribes to that and yet I
don't think this is nothing right and it
even I'll go even further
even if Google quote fixes this even
though this is clearly a feature and not
a glitch and this is extraordinarily
valuable data what if there you know the
when you go on your phone and you look
at when places are busiest that is
partially based on location history and
a lot of people find that to be
extraordinarily useful when you look at
real-time traffic on Google Maps that is
partially coming from location services
and this exact type of thing do you want
to give all of that up maybe the answer
is yes I'm merely playing devil's
advocate I think it's just important
when we think about this this does not
excuse for a second what Google has done
and if it's illegal they should pay the
price for it but a lot of us would
prefer the conveniences that come with
location services being turned on that's
just the reality yeah I'm one of those
people like I'm not hypersensitive when
it comes to my own privacy and security
and this type of thing but I understand
that some people are and some people are
worried about giving Google all their
information all their data all the time
yeah and for those people they should
have the right to turn off those
services I agree I agree that that's
absolutely something they should be able
to do as you could probably tell I have
way more sort of questions in this story
than answers and that's kind of the
reality of the entire thing for some
people this is super binary I don't want
Google tracking me period other people
don't care at all which I as I as I
mentioned have some concerns with most
people recognize the value that comes
from lots of location related services
and apps provided by Google but we still
want to feel like we have some control
over our data and how we are being
tracked and this lawsuit makes us feel
that if the allegations are accurate
that we don't have that control I don't
have the answers I don't have the
solution but I do want you to tell me
what you think we have a voicemail today
about universal basic income our
voicemail number is two one nine two
david p you can call any time of day
whenever you want I don't mind it's just
the answering machine and here is a
voicemail about my recent interview with
Andrew yang 2020 Democratic presidential
candidate about you
I hey David somebody had Andrew hanging
on not too long ago talking about his
UPI plan but it seems to me I just don't
know that
what twelve thousand dollars a year
would really do for a lot of people I
think it seems like like it's great for
someone who's saying making $20,000 a
year at a minimum wage job right because
then they go from twenty to thirty two
and that's a that's a pretty nice bump
but if you're someone who has nothing
like that obviously to a thousand starts
better than nothing but you're still in
poverty right you've still been
struggling to pay rent you know that
that's and especially because on s res
podcast engineering said that his ubi
would be opt-in and if you opt in then
you can no longer get things like food
stamps so I just think like a lot of
people need it the most you're gonna end
up kind of at a wash yeah these are all
reasonable concerns about universal
basic income individually they all have
different answers depending on how you
configure the system but I think even
for people you know the caller said if
you make nothing and you get twelve
thousand dollars you're still in poverty
well yes but now a twenty thousand
dollar a year job in addition to the
twelve thousand does get you thirty two
thousand dollars a year so I I share a
lot of these concerns I just don't think
that these are the specific reasons why
ubi will or won't work I think that
there's just broader picture issues
which I brought up with Andrew yang
about negative income income taxes
versus ubi does ubi add on to other
social welfare programs or does it
replace it every single ubi
proposal answers those questions in a
slightly different way every one of
those concerns is legitimate but I don't
think they are actually the biggest
questions around universal basic income
we have a great bonus show coming up for
you today Donald Trump now says
windmills are bird killers technically
true but he over states the importance
of it as he tries to revive the coal
industry I 95 one of the main East Coast
highways is finally done after 60 years
but now you have to start the repairs
because a lot of those parts now
need some help and we will discuss
whether Melania Trump is trolling her
husband with her entire anti-bullying
campaign david pakman.com slash
membership or patreon.com slash david
pakman show two places where you can
become a supporter of the show and then
as a result get instant access to the
bonus show I look forward to speaking to
you on that Members Only bonus show in
mere minutes
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you